بما أنني كنت سأجري محادثة مع
جدتي حول المستقبل ، فأنت تعلم
أنها تتمنى أن ترى ما
سيأتي لها وهذا ما يحدث عندما
تتحدث إلى هذا المستقبل يشبه أنني أريد
أن أرى ما هو التالي ، فهناك فكرة كاملة
تسمى التفرد أي
الوقت الذي تتحد فيه التكنولوجيا وعلم الأحياء
وكل عام تعيش فيه بعيدًا عن
تكنولوجيا الحياة البيولوجية الخاصة بك ستكون قادرًا
على الحصول على عام أو عامين آخرين ،
الشيء التالي الذي ستفعله هو تخزين
الخلايا الجذعية الخاصة بك ، ما الذي سيتم
استخدامه في  المستقبل ، الخلايا الجذعية التي
يمكن أن تستخدمها لطباعة أعضاء جديدة مثل
القلب الجديد ، والكبد الجديد ، أي عضو تريده
باستثناء الدماغ حتى الآن ، الذي
أحتاجه أكثر من غيره ، فكرة عندما
يحدث التفرد هي
القدرة على رفع  أينما كان مورغان ، كم من الوقت
تريد أن تعيش ما دمت أستطيع ،
نعم ، فإن إحدى الأفكار الكامنة وراء هذا هي
ما سيحدث لذكرياتنا ، ما
الذي سنكون قادرين على فعله بذكرياتنا
بأفكارنا مع كياننا
والفكرة هي أننا سنقوم بتحميل
أدمغتنا إلى محركات الأقراص الثابتة والخوادم
وسنكون قادرين على إنشاء صور رمزية وصور ثلاثية
الأبعاد لأنفسنا.
الهولوغرام هو ما أعطيته لي ،
سنتمكن من التحدث إلى أحفادنا أحفادنا
الأحفاد العظماء من
خلال تفرد
عقولنا وستستمر أجسادنا في
الاندماج مع الآلات التي يمكن أن يكون هاتفك
بسيطًا مثل يدك فقط
ترى المرة الأولى التي ترى فيها أشخاصًا يفعلون هذا
مثل هذا الرجل مجرد شخص مجنون ولكن
يومًا ما هذا الرجل سبب
اتصالك بالهاتف